♪
>>> HAPPY HOLIDAYS AND HAPPY
WEEK 16, EVERYBODY.
HOPE YOU ALL HAD A GREAT
CHRISTMAS AND HAVE A GREAT NEW
YEAR.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE SQUAD
LIVE IN THE BLEACHER REPORT
PRESENTED BY DRAFTKINGS.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS.
HOW WE DOING, HOW WE FEELING,
HOW WE LIVING?
>> DOING GOOD, FEELING GREAT,
LIVING BETTER.
BUT I'M LIVING SO GOOD AND I'M
FEELING SO GOOD AND IT'S THE DAY
AFTER CHRISTMAS.
SANTA CLAUS CAME YESTERDAY.
GUESS WHAT?
GREG IS HERE TODAY.
I'M GIVING AWAY SOME HOODIES.
IF YOU GUYS AT HOME DON'T KNOW,
THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY iPOD.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR
HOODIES.
I HAVE JASON KIEFER 11 IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING, JOE WILL SCORE
A TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, LET'S GET IT GOING.
>> THIS IS THE SHOW WHERE WE ARE
LOOKING FOR THE LOCKS OF THE
WEEK TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
WHO IS GETTING INTO THE END
ZONE?
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL.
WHO'S IT GOING TO BE?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE MOST
POPULAR PICKS WE WERE SENT THIS
WEEK WITH THE FEATURED ODDS
BOARD.
AT THE TIME, PATTERSON HAS BEEN
A STUD ALL YEAR LONG.
COOPER KUPP, THE NUMBER ONE
RANKED PLAYERS IN FANTASY.
WHAT A GOOD YEAR FOR HIM.
RONALD JONES TAKING OVER FOR
LEONARD FOURNETTE.
MIKE WILLIAMS GOING ON THE COVID
LIST.
A DISAPPOINTING RUN FOR SAQUON
BARKLEY.
AND JOSH ALLEN AT THE BOTTOM.
STILL PLUS 180 TAKING ON THOSE
PATRIOTS.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET THROUGH
TODAY.
TELL THEM WHAT YOU'VE GOT ON TAP
TO GIVE AWAY.
>> I'M NOT ONLY GIVING AWAY
HOOD
HOODIES.
I'M GIVING AWAY TWO NFL JERSEYS
OF YOUR CHOICE.
ONE TO THE LUCKY LOCK LEGEND
WINNER OF THE TOURNAMENT AND ONE
TO A LUCKY COMMENTER LIKE
YOURSELF.
SO STICK AROUND, CHILL OUT WITH
ME AND CONNOR.
HERE ARE SOME WINNERS.
YOU GUYS ALSO COMMENT SOME
WINNERS.
YOU MIGHT BE WALKING OUT OF HERE
WITH THE JERSEY.
I NEED GIFTS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY YOU GUYS CAN TYPE
THIS OUT AS I SAY IT.
I NEED WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
CONNOR, I THINK THEY GET THE
MEMO BY NOW.
>> THEY GET THE MEMO BY NOW.
WE NEED TO FIND THAT FOR WEEK
16, THE SQUAD RIDE LEADER, THE
SQUAD RIDE TITLE.
ROUND NUMBER ONE, THE FIRST
SUBMISSION IS FROM McQUAID 18.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> COOKING UP LOCKS, GOING WITH
CAM NEWTON.
GOING TO BE INTERESTING WEEK FOR
THE PANTHERS AS THEY ACTIVATE
SAM DARNOLD.
WE'LL GET INTO THAT IN A LITTLE
BIT.
LET'S SEE THE FIRST CHALLENGE OF
THE WEEK.
IT'S A FAMILIAR FACE.
YOU KNOW HIM BY NOW.
WHAT HOLIDAY STUFF YOU GOT
COOKING UP HERE FOR THIS WEEK.
>> STEPHAN DAVIS.
>> THE BOARD IS BACK.
STEFON DIGGS PLUS 150.
PLUS 150 FOR CAM.
PLUS 150 FOR DIGGS.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW IF YOU WERE ROCKING WITH
CAM NEWTON OR STEFON DIGGS.
I JUST GOT THE BLEACHER REPORT
ALERT SAYING SAM DARNOLD MIGHT
BE PLAYING TODAY.
I KNOW WHAT THE PANTHERS ARE
GONNA DO.
I THINK YOU KNOW.
A HEAVY DOSE OF CAM.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M WILLING TO
PUT MY MONEY ON THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT STEFON DIGGS.
HE DID SCORE A TOUCHDOWN LAST
WEEK.
WE KNOW JOSH ALLEN LOVES TO FIND
STEFON DIGGS.
HE LOVES TO FIND STEFON DIGGS.
HE'S A TARGET MONSTER, LIKE YOU
SAY.
I'M LEANING STEFON DIGGS.
>> I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
HOW DO YOU TRUST THE PANTHERS
RIGHT NOW?
YOU HAVE TO ASK SAM DARNOLD IN
BETWEEN THE 20s TO GET DOWN INTO
THE RED AREA.
THAT'S NOT EVEN IN CAM'S HANDS.
I DON'T TRUST SAM DARNOLD TO DO
THAT NOW.
I THINK EVERYBODY'S FORGETTING
HOW DIFFERENT THE STEFON DIGGS
JOSH ALLEN CONNECTION CAN BE.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO TAKE
BACK THAT DIVISION, THEY NEED
STEFON DIGGS TO GET GOING.
I'M NOT AFRAID OF STEFON DIGGS.
I LOVE THE PLUS 150.
I LIKE IT BETTER THAN CAM.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING
RIGHT NOW?
>> LET ME HOP BACK INTO MY HANDY
DANDY iPAD.
EVAN SAYS DIGGS IS A WINNER.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
STEVE SAYS DIGGS.
THANK YOU, STEVE.
ONE MORE.
ARLOS, I NEED DIGGS TO SCORE.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED.
HIS USER NAME IS LOSO90.
THAT IS FOR THE PRODUCERS.
CONNOR, I THINK I'M GOING TO
MAKE THE DECISION HERE.
WE ARE RIDING WITH STEFON DIGGS
MOVING ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> ROUND NUMBER TWO.
RYAN SCHRODER GETTING IN THE MIX
HERE.
I HEARD IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
COWBOYS NATION GETTING INVOLVED
HERE, WHICH WAS A BIG WINNER FOR
US LAST WEEK.
LET'S SEE WHAT RYAN'S GOT FOR
US.
♪
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> FEED EM, GREG.
EZEKIEL ELLIOTT WHAT A SQUAD
RIDE WINNER BEFORE.
WE LIKE THAT ONE A LOT.
TAKING ON STEFON DIGGS.
IS THIS ENOUGH, GREG?
IS THIS ENOUGH IN ROUND TWO TO
KNOCK OFF DIGGS?
WE LIKE THOSE RUNNING BACKS.
THEY'RE A LITTLE MORE SAFE.
IS THIS ENOUGH TO RUN IT BACK
FOR ZEKE FOR THE SECOND WEEK IN
A ROW?
>> THIS ONE'S TOUGH, CONNOR.
TAKING A WASHINGTON DIVISION
MATCHUP, THIS ONE'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH.
I DO THINK ZEKE CAN GET IN THE
END ZONE.
HE FACED WASHINGTON TWO WEEKS
AGO.
HE DID NOT GET A RUSHING
TOUCHDOWN.
SOMETHING IN THE ATMOSPHERE
SAYING ZEKE IS GOING TO GET A
RUSHING TOUCHDOWN THIS WEEK.
HE HAD ONE LAST WEEK.
I COULD SEE ZEKE GETTING IN THE
END ZONE.
AMARI COOPER JUST SAID HE FELT
LIKE HE NEEDED A BIGGER ROLE.
THAT OFFENSE HAS A LOT OF
WEAPONS.
BUT THEY FLOW WHEN THEY RUN THE
BALL.
I CAN SEE MY GUY ZEKE GETTING
IN, BUT I STILL LIKE STEFON
DIGGS.
I LEAN STEFON DIGGS.
I ALSO LIKE ZEKE.
I'M TORN.
>> I'M NOT OVERLY JACKED UP
ABOUT EITHER.
THEY GOT SO MANY MOUTHS TO FEED
IN THAT DALLAS OFFENSE.
WE LOVED WHAT ZEKE DID FOR US
LAST WEEK.
THERE'S A REASON ZEKE IS A
FAVORITE ON THIS SHOW.
THEY NEED TO GET THAT PASSING
GOING.
THE WASHINGTON SECONDARY DOES
NOT SCARE YOU AT ALL.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO MAKE
EVERYBODY HAPPY, CEEDEE LAMB AND
AMARI COOPER.
WHEN THEY GET DOWN TO THE GOAL
LINE, THERE'S AN EASY ANSWER,
ZEKE ALL DAY.
I'M NOT AFRAID OF DIGGS.
I'M GOOD WITH EITHER.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHERE ROUND
THREE BRINGS US.
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
TOSSUP.
>> THIS ONE IS A TOSSUP.
I HAVE CONNOR, CL 43.
THAT'S NOT YOU IN THE
COMMUNITIES, IS IT, CONNOR?
>> NO.
>> THIS CONNOR IN THE
COMMENTS --
>> I'M PUSHING THIS ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
>> THIS CONNOR IN THE COMMENTS
IS ROCKING WITH STEFON DIGGS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, CONNOR.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I HAVE LEROSE GARZA.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ASHLEY IS IN THE COMMENTS.
ASHLEY SAYS ZEKE BECAUSE HE'S ON
MY FANLT TASY TEAM.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
JESSIE 24 IN THE COMMENTS SAYS
BANG BANG.
I GOT TO MAKE THE CALL.
WE ARE ROCKING WITH EZEKIEL
ELLIOTT MOVING ONTO THE NEXT
ROUND.
>> WE'RE ROLLING WITH ZEKE
AGAIN.
>> YES.
>> ROUND THREE, LET'S SEE IF
IT'S ENOUGH FOR ZEKE TO TAKE
BACK TO BACK WEEKS.
THAT WOULD BE A STUNNER.
THE NEXT ONE FROM IT'S ANTONIO
12.
LET'S SEE IF IT'S ENOUGH TO
KNOCK OFF A FAVORITE IN EZEKIEL
ELLI
QUARTER REL PATTERSON.
THE STOCKING LEGEND.
GOOD JOB BY DAD APPARENTLY.
MAN, TWO RUNNING BACKS, TWO
WORKHORSES.
THEY ARE PLAYING THAT SORRY
LIONS' DEFENSE.
>> I DON'T KNOW, GREG, THIS
MIGHT BE THE ONE.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> I'M HONESTLY TORN, CONNOR.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT ZEKE AND
HIS IMPACT ON THAT DALLAS
OFFENSE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT CAKORDELL PATS
TER
-- KORDELL PATTERSON.
HE CAN SCORE IN MULTIPLE WAYS.
I CAN SEE WHY HE'S MINUS 165.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE LIONS'
DEFENSE WHICH HAS BEEN THE SAME
DEFENSE ALL YEAR.
I'LL HOLD OFF ON THAT LIONS
DEFENSE.
I AM TORN ON THIS.
I'M GOING TO LEAN ON THE
AUDIENCE HERE.
>> LET'S GIVE THEM A CHRISTMAS
GIFT.
GIVE THEM A LITTLE HOLIDAY
SPIRIT.
LET THEM CHOOSE.
WE DIVIDE THIS ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER WEEK AFTER WEEK.
WE BEG SOMETIMES, WE DEMAND.
LET THEM GO MAKE THIS CHOICE.
I'LL BET ON IT.
I DON'T CARE.
>> CONNOR, THIS IS THE HANDY
DANDY TO THE NEW PEOPLE ON THE
SHOW.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHO WE ARE
RIET
RIDING WITH.
BINGHAM 123 SAYS PATTERSON IS
DUE.
HE DID GET CLAMPED UP BY THE
NINERS LAST WEEK, AS EXPECTED.
RYAN THE PANDA SAYS PATTERSON
TWO TOUCHLDOWNS THIS WEEK.
SHANE THE LIFE OF SMITTY SAYS
PATTERSON IS A LOCK.
JUSTIN POTTER 24 SAYS KORDELL
SAID IF MY MOM WORKED THREE
JOBS, WHY CAN'T I PLAY THREE
POSITIONS?
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
WE ARE RIDING WITH KORDELL
PATTERSON TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN
TODAY.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHICS SO I
CAN SHOW YOU WHAT HWE CAN DO
HERE.
JUST LIKE THAT IT WENT UP TO A
PLUS 110.
SHOUTOUT TO DRAFTKINGS FOR
BOOSTING THAT UP FROM MINUS 16 5
TO PLUS 110.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF
YOUR BETS, YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, WE WANT
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
Y'ALL TYPE THAT OUT.
>> THE LORD'S WORK.
UP TO PLUS 110.
>>> WE ARE NOT DONE.
GREG IS NOT DONE BEING GENEROUS.
HE BOOSTED CP.
WE HAVE A SQUAD RIDE LEADER AND
IT'S ANTONIO.
WE HAVE LOTS TO GIVE OUT.
WE'RE NOT DONE.
WE ASKED YOU THIS WEEK IN THE
APP, IN SOCIAL -- NOT A FUN
TOPIC, BUT WE GOT TO KNOW.
IT'S A SAFE SPACE, LET IT OUT.
WHAT WERE YOUR -- 2021?
[INDISCERNIBLE]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY GUYS, THIS IS A SAFE
SPACE.
I LOVE THAT, CONNOR.
YOU GUYS CAN TELL US WHATEVER IS
ON YOUR MIND, DROP IT IN THE
COMMENTS.
LET'S START OFF WITH CONNOR.
IS THIS YOUR BURNER ACCOUNT
AGAIN, BRO?
CONNOR PKA 97 SAYS LAST WEEK
TOOK A SAME GAME PARLAY WITH THE
49ERS MONEY LINE.
DEEBOW OVER 29 1/2 RECEIVING
YARDS, OVER 29 1/2 RUSHING YARDS
AND THE LAST PLAY OF THE LAST
DRIVE.
HE RAN FOR 2 YARDS TO END WITH
29 RUSHING YARDS.
WOW.
CONNOR, I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS
YOUR ON YOUR BURNER, BUT THEY
GOTBU BURNED BY THE HOOK, MAN.
>> IF THIS WERE ME, I WOULDN'T
HAVE SHOWN UP FOR TODAY'S SHOW.
CONNOR NATION RIGHT NOW, WE'RE
STRUGGLING, WE'RE HURTING.
I'M SORRY, MY FELLOW CONNOR.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT GETS WORSE
THAN THAT.
WE'RE ABOUT TO FIND OUT, BECAUSE
WE GOT ONE MORE, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
WE GOT KAI.
KAI T 96 SAYS, STEELERS MINUS 4
1/2 WEEK 6 AGAINST SEATTLE.
THEY RUN BY 3.
COULDN'T CASH OUT BECAUSE OF THE
FREE BET.
YOU SHOULD HAVE HEDGED.
YOU GOT TO HEDGE IN THIS
SITUATION.
WE'VE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
I FLEW OUT TO VEGAS, CONNOR.
I MET UP WITH TONY IN VEGAS.
MY MAN HAD THIS BIG PARLAY.
BUT HE DID NOT HEDGE.
WE LEARNED FROM THAT.
HE LOST.
WE LEARNED FROM OUR MISTAKES.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THIS SITUATION,
YOU GOT TO HEDGE.
CONNOR TALK TO HIM, MAN.
>> HE'S WITNESSED THE HEARTBREAK
FOR VR BETTING WAY TOO MANY
TIMES.
YOU GOT TO HEDGE.
WHATEVER IT IS, DO NOT USE YOUR
FREE BETS ON 12 LEG PARLAYS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO GO SMOOTH.
>> YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO PLAY
THE CASH OUT TO TURN 25 BUCKS
INTO A GRAND.
IT'S TOO SLIM.
I'M SORRY, I FEEL BAD THIS
HAPPENED TO YOU.
I THINK GREG IS GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE IT UP TO YOU.
>> LET ME CHECK OUT THE
COMMENTS, SEE WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
VR BETTING IS IN THE COMMENTS
NOT BECOME ABLE TO CASH OUT.
YES, THAT IS PAIN.
THEN WHAT YOU CAN.
>> CALL YOUR FRIENDS.
>> CALL CONNOR.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
>> CALL YOUR FRIENDS.
LEROSS IS BACK INTO THE COMMENTS
SAYING I LIKE THAT.
LOCKS UNDERWATER IS IN THE
COMMENTS.
YOU ARE WALKING WITH A HOODIE.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION
HERE.
MY GUY KEITH, HE WAS UP ON THE
SCREEN NOT TOO LONG AGO.
I FELT BAD FOR HIM, BECAUSE HE
WAS CLOSE TO 40 K.
I'M GOING TO SEND YOU A HOODIE
AND A JERSEY.
HOPEFULLY I CAN MAKE YOU FEEL
BETTER.
NEXT TIME, NEXT TIME, NEXT TIME
PLEASE HEDGE.
>> DOING IT RIGHT, THOUGH.
A HOODIE AND A JERSEY TO KEEP.
GOOD LORD, THAT'S A ROUGH LOSS.
THAT'S THE LEAST WE COULD DO.
SHOUTOUT TO GREG FOR HOOKING IT
UP.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO BY NOW.
YOU LOCK THE PROP OR YOU WANT
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
I LIKE WHAT WE GOT IN STORE THIS
WEEK.
THIS IS A FUN ONE RIGHT HERE.
>> I GOT YOU, CONNOR.
BEFORE I TELL YOU GUYS, MAKE
SURE YOU GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
LETS US KNOW.
IF YOU GUYS ARE LOCKING IT IN OR
DROPPING IT, LET'S GET RIGHT
INTO IT.
JOSH ALLEN TO THROW FOR TWO OR
MORE TOUCHDOWNS.
JUST NEED TWO TO HIT 100 IN HIS
CAREER.
HE ONLY THREW FOR ONE IN THE
LAST MEETING AGAINST THE
PATRIOTS.
THE BILLS ONLY SCORED 10 POINTS
IN THAT LAST MATCHUP.
DO YOU LIKE JOSH ALLEN TO GO FOR
TWO OR MORE TOUCHDOWNS TODAY?
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE BAD
NEWS FIRST.
THEY'RE PLAYING THE HOODIE.
THEY'RE PLAYING NEW ENGLAND.
THAT DEFENSE IS NASTY.
THEY'RE WELL COACHED, THEY TAKE
AWAY WHATEVER YOU LIKE BEST,
WHICH MEANS STEFON DIGGS, IT'S
GOING TO BE A LONG DAY.
YOUR GUY JOSH ALLEN HAS DONE
THIS 11 TIMES THIS YEAR.
THAT BEING SAID, DON'T BE AFRAID
OF THE PATRIOTS HERE.
THE BILLS HAVE TO GET BACK THEIR
MOMENTUM AND SHOW THEY'RE NOT
PUSHED AROUND THIS DIVISION.
THEY HAVE TO SHOW THIS IS JUST
AS MUCH THEIR AFC EAST AS NEW
ENGLAND'S IN THIS NEW ERA
WITHOUT TOM BRADY.
I LIKE IT.
JOSH ALLEN THROWING FOR TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I LIKE IT TOO.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE BILLS
RUNNING THE BALL.
JOSH ALLEN RAN FOR 109 LAST
WEEK.
RAN THE BALL SEVEN TIMES LAST
WEEK, CONNOR.
JOSH ALLEN THREW THE BALL 54
TIMES LAST WEEK.
JUST DO THE MATH HERE.
THE BILLS HAVEN'T BEEN RUNNING
THE BALL.
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE AN IDENTITY
TO RUN THE BALL.
GUESS WHAT THEY DO HAVE AN
IDENTITY TO DO?
THROW THE BALL.
SO JOSH ALLEN GETTING TWO TD'S
TODAY.
LAST TIME THE WEATHER WAS AN
ISSUE.
TODAY THE WEATHER IS GOING TO BE
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
BRING ME JOSH ALLEN THROWING TWO
TOUCHDOWNS TODAY.
LOCK THAT ONE IN.
>> I LOVE THAT ONE.
DON'T BE AFRAID.
WHAT ELSE WE GOT?
>> LET'S GO TO YOUR BOY COOPER
KUPP.
COOPER KUPP OVER 106 RECEIVING
YARDS.
HE'S HAD TEN CONSECUTIVE GAMES
WITH MORE THAN 90 RECEIVING
YARDS.
THIS IS THE LONGEST STREAK IN
NFL HISTORY.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A LOCK?
DO YOU LIKE THIS, OR ARE YOU
DROPPING THIS ONE?
>> I LOVE IT.
LISTEN I USUALLY DON'T LIKE --
[INDISCERNIBLE]
HE'S THE KING OF 100 YARD
RECEIVING GAMES THIS YEAR.
THE DEFENSE HE'S PLAYING IN
MINNESOTA DOES NOT PUT A LOT OF
FEAR.
I LOOK AT COOPER KUPP AS THE
NUMBER ONE FANTASY PLAYER THIS
YEAR.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS ISN'T 120,
130, SOMETHING TO SCARE PEOPLE
FROM BETTING ON THIS ONE.
WHERE ARE YOU WITH THIS?
>> LET ME READ OFF SOME NUMBERS
TO YOU.
136, 123, 129, 26, 122, 95, 115,
156, 130.
I CAN KEEP GOING, BRO.
HE'S BEEN PLAYING UP YARDS THIS
YEAR.
HE'S BEEN PUTTING UP NUMBERS.
I SAID 100.
I SAID A LOT OF HUNDREDS JUST IN
THOSE SEVEN GAMES I JUST WENT
THROUGH.
I LIKE THIS A LOT.
THAT MINNESOTA VIKINGS DEFENSE
DOESN'T SCARE ME.
I'M PRETTY SURE THEY DON'T SCARE
THE RAMS.
MATT STAFFORD IS GOING TO DROP
BACK.
IF IT AIN'T BROKE, DON'T FIX IT.
I'M WITH COOPER KUPP TO GO OVER
106 YARDS TODAY, SIMPLE AS THAT.
LET ME SEE WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THE COMMENTS.
SPIN SPIN SAYS COOPER KUPP.
REAL BUDDHA SAYS IT IS A LOCK.
JJ SNELL WAS THROWING A LITTLE
BIT OF BAD VIBES INTO THE
COMMENTS.
HE GAVE US A THUMBS DOWN.
I'M GONNA BRIGHTEN YOUR DAY AND
SEND YOU A HOODIE, MAN.
COOPER KUPP, I THINK THAT'S A
LOCK, CONNOR.
>> ME TOO UNFORTUNATELY.
I'M SEEING HIM IN THE SEMIFINALS
OF THE PLAYOFFS.
SO I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
IT'S TIME BEFORE WE GET OUT OF
HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO DROP MOST
FARFETCHED BETS OF THE WEEK.
GREG IS GOING TO GIVE AWAY
HOODIES AT THE END BEFORE WE GET
OUT OF HERE.
HOW ARE WE FEELING THIS WEEK?
>> WE'VE BEEN A LITTLE UP AND
DOWN
DOWN.
THEY'RE NOT BABY BETS.
>> THESE ARE BOLDEST BETS FOR A
REASON.
FEELING GOOD, CONNOR.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET ME KNOW IF YOU
ARE RIDING WITH ME OR CONNOR.
LET'S JUST GET RIGHT TO IT.
TELL THEM WHAT YOU GOT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
THINKING WITH THIS ONE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE SOME FUN WITH
IT.
IT'S BEEN A MISERABLE ROOKIE
YEAR FOR TREVOR LAWRENCE RIGHT
NOW.
I'M BETTING ON HIM TO GET INTO
THE END ZONE WITH HIS LEGS THIS
WEEKEND.
HE WAS GOOD AT CLEMSON AT MAKING
PLAYS WITH HIS LEGS.
I LIKE HIM TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN,
QUARTERBACK SNEAK, QUARTERBACK
DRAW, BREATHE OPTION.
THEY GOT TO GET HIM MOVING IN
THE RED ZONE TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT WITH THIS OFFENSE.
HE DID THIS TWICE, IN BACK TO
BACK WEEKS.
TREVOR LAWRENCE GET
HIM COMFORTABLE, GET SOME
POINTS.
PLUS 450 IS THE REASON WE'RE
HERE.
>> I LIKE THAT.
LET ME GO TO ATLANTA, THE
HOMETOWN OF OUR DIRECTOR HERE.
THE ATLANTA FALCONS IS TAKING ON
THE DETROIT LIONS.
ATLANTA, THEY LOST 2 OF THEIR
LAST 3.
THEY
THE LIONS HAVE WON 2 OF THEIR
LAST 3.
THEY PLAY HARD FOR DAN CAMPBELL.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO PLAY
HARD TODAY.
ATLANTA DON'T SCARE ANYBODY.
THEY BEEN UP AND DOWN, UP AND
DOWN.
I COULD SEE THEM GETTING UPSET
BY THIS DETROIT LIONS TEAM.
I'M TAKING THE MINUS THREE
SITTING AT PLUS 325.
LET ME KNOW IN THE COMMENTS IF
Y'ALL LIKE THIS OR NOT, BUT THIS
IS WHAT WE ROCKING WITH.
>> HE'S FLIPPING THE SPREAD,
SAYING THEY BOTH LIKE THE
FALCONS AT 5 1/2.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE LIONS BY
3.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO COME OUT AND
GO ALL THE WAY LIKE ARIZONA
WHERE THEY JUST WHIPPED THEM
AROUND FOR FOUR QUARTERS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO WIN IT'S
GOING TO BE BY A FIELD GOAL PLUS
25.
>> MICHAEL WITTER.
BELIEVE IN THE APPROACH AND IT
WILL GET YOU THERE.
I'M AUSTIN 19 SAYS LIONS MONEY
WISE, LIKE THAT.
I GOT OAKLAND BLAZE, LIONS PLAY
HARD, MUCH BETTER THAN THAT
RECORD.
OKAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
LARRY HALL OF FAME SAYS HELL
YEAH, GREAT BET.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOU KENNY.
I GOT ONE MORE.
JP GIANT SAYS IS BOTH GREG AND
CONNOR AN OPTION?
YES, BET BOTH.
CONNOR, THE PRODUCERS JUST
WHISPERED IN MY EAR I GOT TO
GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS
LOOKING TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
I SEE JOSE.
HOLD ON.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
HERE WE GO.
SPECKO, YOU GOT A HOODIE TODAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU SPECKO, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY.
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> THAT'S A BIG TIME CHRISTMAS
PRESENT.
AS SOON AS GREG SAYS JERSEY, THE
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME TO GET
UP OUT OF HERE.
WHEN WE SIGN OFF, THROW SOME
MONEY ON KORDELL PATTERSON,
BOOSTED THE PLUS 110 IN THE
DRAFTKINGS SPORTS BOOK APP.
CONGRATS TO ALL OF THE WINNERS.
IT'S ANTONIO, SQUAD RIDE LEADER,
RYAN SCHRODER, TRAMMELL, P
McQUAID.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS AND HE'S THE
MAN, GREG.
HE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK GIVING
AWAY EVERYTHING ALL OVER AGAIN.
WE WILL CATCH YOU SAME TIME,
SAME PLACE NEXT WEEK.